at american university
and also a member of our external faculty we're
just going to talk about rational inference
yeah okay okay thank you thank you this
is as always a great pleasure being here
i will talk today about some of my thoughts
on rational influence to be a bit more correct
it's kind of uh thoughts in progress so i
will start with some kind of of an overview
and then i will go to the uh the basic uh
tutorial so basically we all are basically
using the information including the data that
we have in order to do inference and and design
serial ways uh compiles models and so on but
this information is usually insufficient to get a
unique solution and even more problematic is that
this information is incomplete and quite noisy
to complement even further when we think of
complex system and complex problems then the
problem even magnified this means basically that
we're dealing with underdetermined uh problems we
have more than unique solution uh given the
information including the data that we have
so what are we to do i can think of three
things one is get more data good luck with this
the second one is impose some
assumptions and structures
that are very costly because most often
we cannot really falsify or validate those
assumptions the third approach and this is the
approach i take and many science do is convert
the problem into a constraint optimization one and
this will ensure that we have a unique solution
but the solution will determine uh will will
depend on the choices that we make and i will
talk about it with this background
basically of this within the setup
uh in my talker i will discuss some ideas of
what i mean by rational difference and when i
talk about rational inference which i would define
shortly i'm talking about the inference itself not
whether the agent or the scientist who's doing
the influence is rational or not i'm talking
about this is a different issue i'll touch it on
it a little bit in the back and at the end i'm
talking about the inference itself i would like it
to be rational and i want to define them the the
concept of rationality as it comes to influence uh
i will argue that actually information theoretic
approach in specific maximum entropy and extension
of the maximum principle are basically uh uh
is is is a process that is uh provides
us the providers with rational influence
in short information zodiac approach is a
rational inference with this in mind now
i'm going to move into the basic questions
and then the definitions and then argue
why i think this is a rational inference
good uh so basically the the the basic questions
uh uh that i want to talk about is the concept of
uh rational influence uh so so the basic
question is um uh is such a method exists can we
actually define the concept of of uh rational
elements uh and if we can whether this will
resolve some of the issues that we have always
will be talking about infants and modeling the
issue of modern ambiguity like which is the best
possible model condition of all the information
that we have uh how do we deal with uh uncertain
uncertainty or vastness uh sensitivity and so on
uh and so the basic idea here is again
to to define to think of the concept of
rational inference and see whether
information theoretic can help us in
in this way so those are the basic questions
uh so i want to start with a basic set of
definitions um very briefly but it's important in
the context that we're talking about so influence
per se is basically a statement on the basis of on
the basis of some listening uh inductive inference
from observed to unobserved or to general laws
but it is a guarded uh inference in a sense that
a is supposed to be the conclusion
b is expressed in a guarded world
we put some probabilities on the conclusion uh
this is also known sometimes is under certain
context it's inference to the best explanation
but the question is of course what is best
there is another concept maybe less familiar
in the literature which is called abduction
in the sense of inference to the best explanation
uh this is a type of inference that can be
thought of in the following way it's kind of a
dialogue with the data it is a back and forth
so it's a strategy of reacting to a surprise
we observe a certain surprise certain data
behavior and then we basically engage
with the data we model it we go back to
the the the system say economic system behavioral
system uh try to figure out the serial with the
underlying assumptions we update go back so it's
kind of feedback and falls with the data so it's a
bit of keeping uh open-minded about the endpoint
so it's not just the original data that we have
but rather looking at the original data thinking
outside the box a little bit go back to the theory
update our thinking introduce this
additional information go back to
the data and kind of learn from the data we can
think about it as kind of a type of a diagonal
with the data i will be kind of updating based
on our understanding of the underlying system
so those are just initial set of uh definition uh
the forms of inference that we're interested in
are at least defined so first is deduction what
is inferred is necessarily true if the premise
uh from which it is inferred is true uh so total
the premise guarantees thoughts of the conclusion
so this is a necessary influence
there is no probability it's not a
probabilistic statement
and induction and abduction includes what we
talked about are called actually an unnecessary
in both the conclusions go beyond
what is logically contained
in the premises think about it is more like
mobilistic approach they both depend on
observable information the data that we have uh
and usually it involves with a lot of uncertainty
and and vague information uh but as you mentioned
before with abduction there is some kind of a back
and forth with the uh data and and what we think
or understand our intuition about the underlying
nervous system in the in the discussion today i
take inference to me though in conclusion from
imperfect and incomplete evidences it includes
what we usually call inference um for observable
data as well as modern building and zero building
so under the the the uh umbrella of inference i
mean doing classical inference from observable
data but also constructing a new theory cons or
updating a theory constructing a model and so on
so because it all will be based on the information
that we have been observable or on itself or
we can think about it basically converting
the available but in perfect and incomplete
complex information to knowledge and decision
so this is the concept of influence
that i think about within the context of
today so why do we need a rational version it
goes back to the summary uh that they started
with because we always deal with insufficient
information so there is no unique answer
i write it always if i want to be a bit
guarded i can say almost always but i can't
think of a practical problem where we have enough
information to come up with the um complete and
perfect solution one unique solution so there
is a continuum of possible solutions because
uh the problems are not determined don't have
enough uh information uh example think about it
uh x plus y equals 10 we don't have enough
information if we have one more piece of
information we have a perfect solution but
in reality in science what we basically have
not x plus y equals to 10 but x plus y
equals smaller s ten so then it's not an
issue of the size of the data it's
the issue of uh we never had enough
information because of the more or less because
of the uncertainty ambiguity noise and so on
uh so so the problem is is uh imposed upon
a determined and then we have to think of
a way to handle it so um the solution as i
mentioned earlier i go with the third possibility
converting it into construct optimization
and here is an advertisement i put here
the cover of my recent book on the topic uh so so
we convert the problem to a concerned optimization
so all the information basically enters
in the constraints and when i mean what
i mean with all information it should be
the heart which is the observable data
okay um or consequential i always think
about it as this indirect evidence and
the soft information which would be it includes
everything else that we know whether it's from
theory from intuition from our understanding of
what is going on what we usually call assumptions
structures okay so here we can put it and
then if we put it correctly within the system
then we can only also test it and falsify it
if if needed and the second counterfeit of
course is we need a well defined when we have
decision function or utility function and then
we optimize and choose one of the solution so
of course it boils down to the issue of okay
how to represent the information as concerned
and what uh our decision function to to use
um so uh how is this all related to
to rationality and rational difference
so by rational infants what i mean here and there
could be of course a lot of discussions again just
some thoughts of it because different people may
find the rationality in when it comes to inference
in in in a different way the way i think about it
is uh again i mean the inference itself okay and
again i'll talk a little bit about rational
agent in a little bit so we're talking about
the inference itself um and what do i
mean by rationality here i mean there
is some ranking of the possible solutions and all
information this is the important part because
anytime you do a construct optimization you have
a natural ranking of the possible solutions this
is what the decision function we do the utility
function will do for us same thing if you think
of preferences uh or what economists use called
utility function or decision theory and so on but
the essential part is that all information
is accounted for there will be no implicit
information that we don't know where it came from
in the inference and this is why i like to call
it rational influence and in this way it's kind
of parallel the concept of of a national agent
we make our decision if we are rational based
on some our preference is a utility function
and given the information that we have but there's
no implicit uh uh uh uh information or preferences
that we cannot account for this is why yeah maybe
just give an example of what would what would be
a situation where there are such complete
where there is such implicit information is
not accompanied yeah i i would oh let me first
because first it's a it's a good question uh
first i want to define the objective i believe
we'll give it and then i will basically argue that
many other objective functions or inferential
approaches or what statisticians will call
estimators are not rational
under this definition okay uh
okay so um sorry i uh so so we
have a construct optimization
and then the question is uh how to uh uh define
all of the information so all the information
will enter as constraints and ordering and
liking is based on some decision function
and the the reason for this is that uh because
uh the problem that we deal with are usually
under determined then we may have multiple
solutions so we want all of the informations
basically to enter into the constraints and
the question of course what should be the uh
objective function the decision function that
uh i propose you that i'm going to use uh is
shown in entropy not any other entropy uh shalom
entropy and this will ensure basically that it is
optional in the senate it will give us the least
biased inference the influence that is based only
on the information that we use the information
in the constraints this could be the how data
and it will be all of the assumptions of the
structure that we want to impose but we can test
it also we can falsify it but this is it nothing
else so it's very objective it's it's independent
of whether the the bodybuild agent is rational
the agent could be irrational but if the agent put
this into the machine then the influence itself
will be rational now so so the idea is is to to uh
use channel entropy now to america's question
any other objective any other decision-making
way all estimation approaches showed in a bit
uh can be put within inferences can be put
within the framework of constraint optimization
if you think about it any likelihood
can be actually formulated in its doing approach
and then it will be a constrained optimization
unfortunately estimation i mean those of you
that work with least square any other type of
influential approach um any uh method let's say
if you think of say uh a probability distribution
okay based on some moments of the distribution
what the um channel entropy will give us where
the moments will be the constraints the decision
function will be shunned it will give us
the flattest possible uh probability distribution
the one that is less bias in the sense that
out of all infinitely many possible
probability distribution that satisfy those
say m moments this would be the letters the
one that is closest is possible to uniformity
with uniformity here in information theory
referred to as the state of maximum uncertainty
because everything is equally likely any other
objective how can i have some pictures at the
end if we get to this interest that look at
some numerical examples any other objective
be it square with any likelihood or any higher
level of entropy function or generalized entropy
will give us a probability distribution in this
case that will be not as flat now the difference
uh yeah i have a quick question just to make sure
i'm following you does it mean that basically the
rationality function you have means the more
rational means the more discriminative like
the more discrepancies you would have
between the different options you're ranking
i i may have missed part of it sorry oh sorry um
the decision function you're picking that means
that the criteria you want to satisfy is
to have a decision function that is the
most discriminative as possible right that
is like the strongest discrepancy in it
it's not it's it's basically what you do here is
you're maximizing the missing information the only
information that you're using basically
is the information in in the constraints
so if you have no constraints you start with
a uniform and then you put the constraints
and it takes your father and if the constraints
are informative it takes your father and father
away but it keeps you as close as you
can to uniformity any other decision
will take you further away than this solution from
your deformity and the question then is where this
additional discrepancy came from and this is why i
call a disappoint rationale because the other part
it means that the information comes from
the decision function but i can't really
know or figure out where it is coming from
it may come from some basic action behind
a certain decision function or somehow
but it is an information that is not
directly accounted for it means that
somebody assumed that say i'm using
a d square or that i'm using like likelihood
by certain higher enthalpy of sardis entropy
and then there is an additional information
that comes from the decision process itself
because the constraints remain exactly
the same so i'm using the same information
but i'm getting a more informed solution so the
question is where is this informed additional
information the marginal information coming
from and this is why i like to think about it
is as shannon entropy ensures that the inference
itself is rational there is no hidden information
so this is the basic idea uh of course it
has clear parallel with the traditional
project because all approaches and showed in a
bit can be thought of as constraint optimization
and and of course the format
is suitable for falsifying
the constraints and information that we have
because as you know any concerned optimization
method you can do any classical statistical
test within this just basically by
by looking at the value of your
decision objective function
and then converting it into a certain
statistic of instance into say chi-square or or
okay uh so
so if we go back to to the basic discussion
we had earlier on on the definitions
uh then basically all what we said here that
um like all the inferences the conclusions
go beyond the uh uh our premises that we
have however in this case uh the premises
are well defined everything is more defined all
the information being solved assumptions structure
whatever we want our intuition economic zeroing
any other theory will be within the constraints
so in in in just to show it in non-mathematical
way basically so i argue here and and it's not my
own argument it's the fact that all influential
methods basically can be constructed as constraint
optimization be it least square or likelihood
empirical activity whatever we have in mind
so we have it we optimize a certain function uh
subject to the constraint and the constraints in
the information that we have in classical
physics there are called our conservation laws
but if they are specified correctly in statistical
language think about those as sufficient
statistics if we impose those constraints
correct we find all of the available information
in the data that uh we have uh you can also think
about it as as the behavior those are basically
the it they capture the behavior of the system
those are all the rules that basically govern the
behavior of the underlying system so those
are the constraints and of course if we talk
about probability distributions we we need to
think of just a normalization okay uh so what
uh certain decision function to optimize i i
mentioned it so i'm not gonna go over so out uh
in this talk i argue that the channel entropy
is the one that relates to the least biased
influence only the information we have
is used so there is no subjectivity
there there is no additional information
that enters for the objective function
the constraints can also be specified in more
complicated a problem with a lot of you and others
in the institute and many other
places about one complex system
then uh the constraints also because
we have additional level of ambiguity
model ambiguity in addition to uncertainty
and some other issue of dynamics and so on
then the constraints can be uh basically
basically uh uh uh defined and constructed as
a quality stochastic meaning that there will be
some level of uncertainty that is added to each
one of the constraints okay which is actually
pretty trivial to do but it's important uh bios
we can incorporate piles in the decision function
in this case it will not be we would change it
from say shanon entropy to the callback label
uh uh uh information divergence but this is uh
uh and the soft information here it can be
falsified or like i write your validated
body that means just by using statistical
tests but it's up to certain probability
and also it's interesting in some
cases and and i cannot argue that
i know how to do it for all problems so
uh the soft information actually can be
measured outcome are transformed into
informational unit because the decision function
is shown on entropy so we can convert the uh the
uh all of the information all of the constraints
we can measure the relative information relative
to all the other concern it won't be absolute but
it will be relative let's say constraint number
two out of five is the most informative if you
want to think about it mathematically when you
solve the console optimization you're going to
use a lagrangian approach so the lagrange the
lagrangian the lagrange are multiplying for this
constraint will be the largest in magnitude
uh relative to the other so it tells you and
then you can compare this magnitude into bits of
information exactly so so we can rank this and we
can understand uh our information and relative
information in in a nice way uh just a note
uh uh like i mentioned and and so and and this
means that that uh even when the concerns are
stochastic and we deal with
a very complicated problem
then we can accommodate for modern
ambiguity and this will take us to the uh
best possible model it won't be the optimal model
and it won't be the tools because when we deal
with you know insufficient information there is
not really tools we don't we never really gonna
uh get into the perfect theory of the
perfect solution we hope to approach it
uh as we have known more information but even
if we approached it we never really can prove
all the only thing we can do is falsify um but at
least under this approach we can do all of this
and again just to make uh to connect it directly
to likelihood uh is basically if you think about
it is what is the classical likelihood classical
likelihood is basically the constraints we specify
together with our choice of decision function
this is the classical likelihood for example if
the constraints are lineal let's say arithmetic
moments and this decision function is shanon here
then we will get an exponential likelihood
exponential solution which means that the
likelihood is exponential if for example the
constraints are logarithmic and the decision
is shown on then the solution will be a power so
the likelihood yeah so you you've said a lot about
the decision function and the constraints but
you haven't said anything about the optimization
method is are there any assumptions that
have to go into the how the optimization
takes place so you optimize so i put you put all
of the uh you you put all of the uh information
as constrained you chose a decision function
and then you optimize so let's say lagrangian
so you construct the lagrangian here and then you
solve it with respect to the multipliers and then
you get the optimal solution so you're assuming
that you know the decision function has to be
i'm sorry it has to be a well-behaved decision so
it has to be uh continuous and differentiable and
okay yeah uh
yeah i thank you i i skipped it and
i won't i think before and well we
have better talk yeah okay it it have
to to we want to ensure that the the
decision-making research
and get a unique solution uh
the idea of of our stochastic constraints or
putting some uncertainty about the concern
allows us also to handle a very complicated uh
optimization when we have non-linear constraints
um but you are but but but the objective function
has to be what we have done in channel n to be is
a way we have uh uh our function okay uh so to to
put it all to summarize everything uh so far uh
so uh i i argue that the constraint optimization
the channel entropy as the decision function is a
rational inference and again the idea here is the
inference itself is rational meaning there will be
no additional information that entails that
we don't really know where it's coming from
so it is independent of the use of the
researcher and it provides a framework for a
large class of influential problems because
basically we can put within this framework
almost any problem simple or complex there
are no implicit or hidden assumptions here
everything is on the table all the information
is in the constraints or if you want if we have
some information that come from coe it can be
incorporated into the piles into the objective
function which we call piles but this is something
that again we know where it's coming from um
it allows us it accommodates for modern ambiguity
or uncertainty so then we get what i like to think
about it is the best approximate model it won't be
the best possible model because it's a simpler
version of reality but it's the best approximate
uh model in the center that it takes care of
everything else that goes on in the complex
system that we analyze um out of all the possible
solution it select the the least informed one the
one that is closest to uniform if you think about
it in terms of say a probability distribution
it is the least biased influence in
the sense that all of the inf we use
only the information that we incorporate into
the problem nothing else on the outside is coming
now it also had some extrematic justification
which i'm not talking about i did not talk about
and the exomatic justification of there are two
sets of those one is on the decision function
itself the exomes behind channels entropy
which are not satisfied of course by all
other generalized entropies all we can think about
it exon that are defined on the inference itself
because there are two sets of axioms uh i didn't
talk about those but there are set of exerms that
we can use to justify the function the decision
function or the inference itself it is efficient
in the sense that it is statistically efficient
if you think of statistical efficiency you can
compare it to the efficiency of say a likelihood
uh which is is possible so it is statistically
uh efficient it is also computationally efficient
because if you specify your constraints correctly
and you optimize then you get a good uh way of
basically understanding that you you basically
found all of the rules that govern the system
basically that you try to analyze okay so you
don't need any additional information
so uh what i mean by computationally uh
are efficient that it would be uh because
the the uh model that you get is based
on the minimally needed information once
the if the consents are defined correctly
you don't need additional information you're able
to exactly characterize the system that you want
so it will be no more parameters and any concerned
optimization model can be converted into its dual
form which will be an optimization because the
entropy is the way the channel entropy well behave
function then you will get a where we have uh you
can see what it likely if you want if you think
about it from the dual arm constraint and it will
be as efficient as any other likelihood function
uh so i i don't know if i explain it correctly
but but the the um generally not but but the basic
idea here is that it's both statistically and
computationally efficient uh uh certain different
ways there will be no likelihood uh approach there
can be computationally more efficient than this
it is also simple in but but simply in in
in the simplistic way of c it will be the
simplest possible model in the center it will be
based on the sim the smallest number of parameters
so it's simple in terms of parameters okay
because if again once the the information is
specified correctly it means that you don't need
more information but the information that you're
using the constraints is everything that you
need you don't need more but you cannot leave
this best if you want to fully characterize or or
or build your theory so it's the simplest possible
model uh and and also we can uh uh falsify
uh and validate in the traditional way
uh some comments uh how is this related to
uh abduction because of said abduction is
a dialogue with the data you start when you
influence you go back to this theory and the
data you update you learn some more the idea
here that it's it's directly related because
uh with abduction we want each stage
each part of the dialogue to be rational
so if we use this approach then we go back
to the theory back to the system we update
we get some more information we use our intuition
whatever we have then uh we can get uh back to the
constraints and we specify them then each
stage of the process needs to be rational
so this is the way i think it is related um
that's the agent of the model need to be uh
sorry rational uh again we concerned him with
nationality of the influence itself yet of
course it makes sense that the model will be a
rational but it's not necessary if we give the
model that is not rational this black box for
specific problem then at least the influence
would be rational but of course uh uh one uh words
that the agent itself would be rational but again
whether the agent is rational or not the
issue here is the uh rationality of the
inference uh concern and this is just going
back to the question that i started with uh
with the basic idea that uh i tried here to
answer those questions in a very general and
brief way uh that we started um so this is it
basically uh and i have some uh pictures if
there's interest that shows some examples where
the um uh classical maximum entropy for example
give you the most uninformed and any other
decision function uh gives you more informed
solution but i'll stop here if there are questions
about this we can go to the pictures thank you
all right thank you so much for the talk i found
one of your slides near the end i think you said
something about it sort of being independent
of the researchers but then you also talk
about incorporating prior information so in what
sense is it independent from the researchers if
they're incorporating their particular prior
knowledge so by my information i i'm talking
about the fundamental definition of a pile that
it comes from outside that it's not part of the
data that you come from say part of the theory
so for example if you tell me that you model a
a a problem that you know
that is saying empowerment
then it gives you some idea of how to construct
your information to solve the problem basically
so it will be something that comes from outside
that i'm certain about yet still the data can take
over because just like in the basin approach uh
here it's slightly different but in a similar way
the data the the the evidence can take over the
bios however when you deal with uh unlike in the
classical basin when you deal with uh insufficient
information and under determined problems
then the bios are very important because they
can take you away if the bios are misspecified
they will take you away from the supposedly
better solution very very fast so again when
i'm talking about bios i'm talking about it
in in the classical ways that it comes from
outside the system from theory that
you are certain about or pretty certain
so i'm trying to map this into say statistical
inference in machine learning like how where you
might have say a bunch of you're trying to decide
if photos or dogs are cats and you have a bunch of
feature vectors of cats and a bunch of feature
vectors and dogs and you know normally you would
do like a logistic regression kind of thing with
a loss function how how would you use this in that
kind of context how would you so what would be
the constraints so so it a a set of constraints
with uh say image reconstruction will be i
can just take a uh so so you have all of your
big image with a lot of pixels then i would just
say for ex just as an example i would take the
moments and you can define the moments which would
be just like aggregated say so you can take the
moments of if you want of each one each column so
by definition it's already undetermined problem
you can also take diagonal moments if you
want whatever information you think you need
uh and those will be the constraints now in this
and then you also can add additional coordination
for example uh so that so there could be
additional set of of constraints that of the
way you construct the moments you allow for say
uh first neighbor correlation or exponential decay
based on based on how far the the cells are from
saying figure out ahead of time what features you
think would be relevant like the moments of the
you can yeah you can figure this so you can just
try for example an experiment that i did on facial
recognition or fingerprints uh i basically just
i didn't even use the diagonal moments and it
did pretty good actually and and extremely fast
and i just used just to see if it works basically
just the uh uh horizontal and vertical moments
but of course if you have more information
then then you can incorporate it let's say
you know that it's a character or a dog
then you can put this in your bibles
but but this is just a fire match you're
right i mean every problem and i didn't search
is specific this is the basic
mechanism of the framework
but each problem is absolutely specific and and in
the specification of the constraints it's the most
it's the basic issue yeah and and and like
anybody you know what would be the structural form
right what is the assumption but here at
least we can test it and try to validate it
you see if i'm understanding uh this right so
so we have the cat and the dog images are in
the cat of the non-cat images and there are some
statistics that we are interested in about those
images and maybe those are like the means of the
rows or whatever um is the idea that we have some
dish we start off with like assuming there's like
a uniform distribution over those statistics and
then ask okay what is the district are we trying
to learn what the distribution for cats looks like
or non-cats looks like or how
am i how should i imagine that
so basically if if you have an
image then think about it as
what i was talking about like image reconstruction
so i have an image but i can't really see
what individual or if it's really a cat or a
dog then uh you know one way would be to go
you know it's probably specific specific
but to go based on on uh the moments of of
this pixel and this reduces the dimensionality
so it's very very efficient if you think about
it it's extremely efficient especially once you
convert it to to its unconstrained optimization
but the the most of the information will
come from the correlation among the the cells
this is where a lot of the information so you
incorporate this correlation within the moments
very much like in the classical way if you
think that your data are autocorrelated
then you add an additional piece of information
the model is autocorrelated and you allow the
model to do it so you can do it here within
the same framework it's a bit different but
the same idea so so you put all the
information that you think is essential
but then of course you look at it and and
and you uh uh fix it accordingly you you're
learning from from you start with a set of
constraints you see whether it gives you
something that makes sense if it doesn't then
you update it but you learn from this because
you see that you know that it's human but
you keep seeing only kids you know in in your
reconstruction so you know that something
is wrong so then you update it accordingly
you